work this is not a game we prepare  that's a good point my apologies and  also they're on the other team  they're the enemy  oh shots fired the other night  our friends over at espn laid down the  gauntlet jeff van gundy  the last thing i want to do stan is get  in the middle of  any kind of family spat is everything  okay with the van gundy's  hey look i and i love my brother and  there's absolutely no hard feelings  so no animosity whatsoever between you  and jeff  none on my part at all no not at all  don't even think about it  i did notice before the game you're  excellent at darts  you just have a high skill level oh we  didn't take that down before before we  got  started here yeah that's that's in your  plexi glass  cubicle i guess that sort of gave me  away